[Applause]
[Music]
hey
kids we smoked away the last 40 minutes
yeah
never mind that you didn't see anything
welcome to fat man beyond i'm
kevin smith
i am
you know how they say like smoke them if
you got them well i did
so um
it sounds like don't worry it's not
covered that was all [ __ ]
non-coveted
uh welcome back looks like the stream is
up and running looks like everything's
copacetic man
uh no strobing that seemed very pokemon
for a minute there
i was afraid it was going to give people
seizures or something uh
looks like we're
back to normal thanks to the uh will
wilkins who came in and
did something banff man are you involved
still or no
uh
bamf yeah
uh will had to reset up all the stream
on the youtube end and i had to restart
my encoding computer
so look at that the we weren't hearing
it we we produce the show on one
computer
and then send it through an hdmi cable
essentially to another computer that
sends it to the internet
and uh
the production computer was good the
encoding computer needed to be reset
so that's how that's how we got here
um
[ __ ] sorry i asked that was so boring
but thank you perfect
thank you for this
tech talk
thank god we don't have a sponsor
tonight
sponsor would have been deeply
disappointed yeah
brought to you by radio shack in 1993.
if there is a sponsor it is uh
uh uh me and ralph garman doing
hollywood babylon on saturday night 10
o'clock at flappers comedy club
in burbank tickets at seasmod.com
and listen kids
just cause like you're not in los
angeles or burbank
you know doesn't mean you can't buy a
ticket we take pity purchases all the
time
[Music]
some kid in idaho is like i like the cut
of your jib i'm gonna buy a ticket
regardless and stuff give it away to
some local fan i'm just not trying to
tell you what to do just ideas like a
tip jar
tip jar
replace that tit you remember ramblin
rose
yes i think that was i think uh what's
his name robert duvall was the line in
the movie at one point he goes replace
that tit
put him on the glass um how you been
captain i'm i'm hanging in there my
friend busy is a as a one-legged man in
an ass kicking contest but
one of my favorite southern aphorisms
um my because i have i have relatives
who live in in maryland which if you're
in new york if you're in new york or
maryland is the deep south
um
uh yeah so yeah i've been i've been busy
gonna stay busy gonna be busy until i
don't know third week of february
um honing in on locking picture on
splinter
how's that going man being in the
editing room yeah well it's it's it's
going well it's you know virtual editing
which means that i'm i'm i'm not sitting
next to my editor just
to be longer make that one shorter do we
have any other tags editing room is
virtual as this is virtual is this the
editing less the editing room more the
editing zoom i
see what you did there
consonant replacement
but yeah once we have the locked picture
then we can start talking to
our music uh lovely music people namely
bear mccreary
who's going to be doing uh doing the
shiny shiny music
for their query from
masters of the universe netflix and
masters of the universe masters of the
universe is bear mccreary and that's all
about it it's such a great score for
that show
um and he had like
a half hour well 20 minutes
2 4 6 8
10
maybe like maybe he had to do 120
minutes of music for the whole series
how long was splinter
15 minutes
so he don't have to write nearly as much
music so pound for pound you may wind up
getting him better score if that's
possible i mean honestly i only need him
for like one chunk of the movie because
the i think the sound design is going to
be doing lots of the heavy lifting
early on so it's like he's got three
minutes of music if you can if you can
pull out three minutes of music then
we're in business
let me tell you something about bear
mccreary man
he [ __ ]
jerks off three minutes of music before
he gets out of bed in the morning
and it's better music mark than most
will ever give you
so you're gonna get something gold he's
wonderful yes um he elevated our our
show he made
that show so much better with his score
i was just on the sound mix uh stage
today myself
um we are we're all
pretty much done here with clerks three
so we're picture locked with the
exception of
real zero
you know what real zero is in the motion
picture industry please tell me educate
me
vanity logos
the cards that go up front
so i've watched today i watched reel one
two three and four
um really great i had very minimal notes
um
the uh
i'm more of a fan of like use what's on
the track you know because most of my
movies are all dialogue and stuff
but uh they sound designed some nifty
things into it and whatnot particularly
as uh i mean this is not spoilers the
character randall quite like the
character kevin smith
has a heart attack in the motion picture
and uh they did some cool things with
the heart attack moment like audio wise
that i was like oh [ __ ] right on
um and we've watched real five
tomorrow they they wanted a little more
time to do real five
uh so tomorrow i go and watch the di
playback which is
you know that's the
leron our dp went in and color we used
to call color correction back in the day
but now it's called the dia
um he went and adjusts everything so i'm
going to see the movie
the way the dp always saw the movie
um which is different from what i've
been seeing in all the dailies that uh
you know that i cut together and stuff
like that so
tomorrow will be interesting in terms of
like oh so that's what clerk's three
looks like
he gave me a preview so that well i
don't think there'll be too many
surprises
um and then at night we go back to the
sound mix and listen to the last real
real five
yeah and any fixes from one two three
and four um how much longer before you
have a version of of splinter that you
want to share with
your nearest and dearest
um you know i think that once once we
have picture lock um
and once we get some sound design in
there for real
um i think i think we'll have a
we'll have something that can convey the
total experience
um we've got some temp score in there
now which can hold until we get the real
deal
um but you know hopefully not much
longer hopefully you know within
three four weeks we'll have a thing that
i can start uh slipping to trusted
friends and advisors and
you know me i'm always shredding
everything yeah just tearing apart
especially after it's picture locked and
we can't do anything about it
how do you feel about it as you see it
takes shape um i feel pretty good i feel
pretty good you know it's it's also it's
helpful
having
had a little bit of experience in tv and
editorial and realizing exactly how much
can be done
um
even while you're in there like we're
gonna have to do a little bit of of
adr additional dialogue recording just
for some story clarity points but like
i've seen people
you know conjure completely different
storylines
um using adr and over-the-shoulder shots
and suddenly oh there's a whole plot
thread i didn't know we had like nope
yep we invented it in post
we didn't shoot anything like this we
wrote it all here in this room and
actors record it wherever they are and
we made it happen so
the amount of power you have to affect
story in post uh continues to astonish
me
and getting to write another draft of
the script
yeah you know and if it all holds and
and
yeah i mean it's coming along really
well it's coming along really well but
i will always know the shots we didn't
get and that i think will haunt me until
the end of my days all right
yeah it's like man wish we got mad
man we should have gotten that damn
version of that
i never have that there's never like uh
i always i mean i get everything i want
to shoot but i don't ever want to shoot
anything complicated so it's always
pretty easy to get everything you want
at the end of the day
yeah um so i've never had that like oh
man
and a few things like we did uh like a
couple pickups on this
flick we have there's like a
montage uh at one point in the flick
that has a bunch of people
like you know famous friends and stuff
and so
um we shot a tiny piece of it back east
when we were making the movie
but a majority of it was shot afterwards
when like other people freed up and and
stuff
and um
i don't know why i'm [ __ ] telling
this story
uh you always got the shots you wanted
not to turn free shoots thank you um
even like you know when i was done with
the movie
i remember i said the lions gate at one
point i was like look we don't need to i
know the plan was to get a bunch of
cameos and stuff but
the the four that we had that we shot
back east are like plenty and they're
funny and we could just go with this
but they were like
if you have them and they're wanting to
shoot it they're like you know that's
just pure sugar moment in the movie
and uh it did it turned into a wonderful
sequence in the flick uh i am a big
fan of clerks 3 and i'm sure you know
that goes without
saying but
some people don't like their own stuff i
i'm a big guy like what we got because i
shot exactly what i wanted to get yeah
you know but i'm not an ambitious guy
i think it was a lot of it was this
schedule
you know like four days we had really
three days on the playing stages
and uh and so it's all right let's get
everything we have to get
you know let's do two three takes if we
got it we feel good about it great but
then look in the background it's like
man i wish we just had a little bit more
time and i think that that's always you
know as i understand it always the the
the sort of locomotive behind you is the
clock
and time in a very real way in a way
that it's almost in no other way in life
time is money when you're shooting um
anything i don't
i don't i don't think there's a single
filmmaker
i don't care how much money you have
whether you've got a hundred dollars to
make a movie or a hundred million
dollars
eventually it always comes down to like
we're running out of time and we don't
have enough money like
it doesn't matter what your show is man
like yeah it just happens
um but you know nothing nothing
catastrophic
um so yeah i i like it now i'm but i can
it's one of those like we've been dating
for a little bit you know i think i like
it
um
but i can also see a path towards love
and hopefully it goes that way
it's adorable man you're so you're so
new to this
i love everything i do i'm like oh this
is brilliant oh my god i love it i'm
such a huge kevin smith fan
i uh it only it's only it's never like
how do i take this from like to love
it's like how do i bring down this
distasteful amount
of love that i have for the work that
i'm doing
i love kevin smith movies because like
when i'm finally done i'm like oh my god
it's like they made this movie
just for me and then i remember like you
did you [ __ ] dumbass toner
but yeah we're gonna be finished man by
monday everything's locked and
and then uh we hand it over to lionsgate
i think we're delivering like you know
not to tell tales out of school but
i've been told we're delivering a month
early that's how i had a schedule we are
look at you
being awesome what's your excuse
splinter
yes this one producers is just rising me
from
blowing my deadlines
the uh
i guess we should dive into it we can we
got some not no
no sponsors other than
hollywood babylon
lappers
comedy club this weekend saturday night
10 o'clock me and ralph garman tickets
at
seasmod.com somebody in the comments was
like a millionaire begs for people to go
see a show i'm like how do you think i'm
a [ __ ] millionaire dude
because i'm shameless and i will beg
people to go see my show
simple life lessons um all right
let's dive into it man we've got uh
things to review
uh
let's start with uh the book
of the mandalorian thing
the book of better fat some have said
mandalorian chapter 17.
the book of boba wear boo-boo
um
episode 15 is that what it's called
amanda laureate yeah after 17 of the
mandalorian slash chapter 5 of
an episode that you know i've seen the
general consensus online and twitter
seems to be like this was the best
episode of boba fett
ever you know even though he's not in it
um we got to see our old friend the
mandalorian again
uh they made
huge story leaps
with that character
on a show that wasn't even
that
that that character show like i mean
spoilers and again spoilers of course
kids
you know boba's been out for a red-hot
minute now um
but uh we're gonna spoil the hell out of
it
um
now i forgot what i was going to spoil
it with because i was so busy
putting up spoilers
the caveat and tour
i got incepted by my own spoiler
um
oh oh
[ __ ] if they're like you're a
mandalorian no more he's not even the
mandalorian anymore yeah he's not even a
mandalorian
so what do they call the show when it
comes back
the art is formerly known as the
mandalorian
that's an old joke from the
east 2000s kids taft cam
um wow man like it was that that's it's
one thing to be like you know hey look
who's here man like [ __ ] laverne and
shirley are popping by happy days one
thing to have a guest appearance by
mandalorian whole [ __ ] episode was
like an episode of the mandalorian oh my
god i saw him continue to go to the
mandolin
and they'd [ __ ]
like
move this to the mandalorian story
forward
at the same time we even got amy sedaris
coming back the great amy stars yeah i
feel like if i was if i was a man-line
watcher who decided to sit out boba fett
because i didn't care that much i
probably would be a bit pissed because
when i come back to the mandalorian
he's going to be on a whole different
mission than i thought he was going on
he's got a whole different ship he's got
a little bundle of joy to give you're
going to be like where's the cool ass
spear we spent the whole [ __ ] season
going after
that blew my mind she's like what do you
want the spirits like you know burn it
make some clothes for a foundling or
whatever but you know and also make this
little outfit or whatever
but like i'm like wait no way the spear
angle and the spear is gone which i
guess you don't really need the spear a
hat on a hat because he's got the dark
saber and we got to see him wield the
dark saber
on boba fett not an episode of
mandalorian again
um but i wasn't complaining i was happy
as hell man um didn't even notice that
we you know stepped away from boba fett
completely
um
one thing that i was like and i'm not
using this to shade boba fett i'm
enjoying boba fett i know a lot of
people are
out there have issues and stuff but you
know me my bar is low and i'm very easy
and i'm like look i had that action
figure he's doing the thing
um so i'm very easy uh bar to clear so
to speak
uh that being said
this episode uh
you know
it reminded me
one of the things i loved about boba
fett through most of my life was that we
never took his helmet off
and you know in boba fett now up to
episode four or whatever we're
accustomed to
boba fett you know just going oh natural
charlie brown style and stuff so
and it don't matter i understand story
wise he's not a mandalorian and so forth
and such like i'm i'm not dumb i'm just
saying
this episode
seeing
how do you pronounce his name jin jar
jar and jin in
john
seeing his guy never take his helmet off
just makes all every scene cooler
where you're just like i don't know what
he's [ __ ] thinking
like it's so weird because i remember
when the first spider-man came out i
didn't like the scene where spider-man
and green goblin were on the rooftop
talking to each other because i was like
nobody's mouths are moving these look
like action figures
but maybe it's because you know boba
fett has been an action figure for most
of my life before he became
you know a character
beyond the few appearances he's had in
movies and then mandalorian provides
like you know i know it's completely
different character but he [ __ ] looks
like boba fett and stuff
but seeing him wear the helmet the whole
time i was like
instead of missing a little bit on boba
fett like keep that helmet on man like i
don't want to know what you're thinking
like it's kind of you shrouded in
mystery man it just makes him a [ __ ]
badass um
but yeah i love the whole [ __ ]
episode and i could not believe
how
forward they moved the ball
on boba's time and dime and you know
he got a new ship as you mentioned
and it's got no room bam bam jump in and
tell people what you're talking about
before the show bamf
i just said i can't wait to see little
grogu in the in the droid dome
in the bubble why do you think that's
gonna happen because if it doesn't it's
a crime
rude i concur
what is wrong with me that that never
occurred to me all i thought was like
well there's no droid there and i'll
leave it at that like i didn't [ __ ]
think like that's where gogu's gonna sit
they put the little fish dome on it it's
like he put he put the child seat in his
nebulin fighter
like that's adorable
did you see i think that's the one
anakin
used in episode one like the markings on
it underneath the cockpit and everything
are the same
spit take legit spit take
wow
all
right he said it was the queen of
naboo's
cruiser right he was like this cruiser
was made for the queen of debut or
commissioned for the queen naboo
who was the queen of naboo by the queen
i think it was who was the queen of
debut
wasn't it
yeah
i mean it's it's the smallest of small
worlds
if that [ __ ] [ __ ] that tiny anakin
was like this is better than bob racing
ends up in a junkie on
tatooine but okay
i mean tatooine is kind of like
the center of that universe though like
it's like a magnet it seems like
i mean think about how much star wars
there is out there hours wise and think
about how much of it revolves around
tatooine
you know i think it's not an empire and
it's not in empire strikes back is the
only movie of the original six
that doesn't have tatooine in it
and it's only empire
force awakens and last jedi that don't
have it out of all nine so six of the
nine movies tatooine is in and then like
basically every episode of the tv shows
so there's something about that planet
it's like the center of the universe
well let's break it down
can't be hoth you need a lot of snow
could be indoor but you know you got to
go hang out in the redwoods all day long
sand
they got that in california for days so
mm-hmm
or tunisia
yeah jacob brown and chat just said
desert equals cheap
yeah that's i guess that kind of what i
was thinking like
it's accessible so it's gonna make it
did you guys think uh they do so much
desert indoors too but only at night
stuff
uh what do you think they they made the
the spear into for grogu do you think
it's a lightsaber
do you think it's a
little i thought it was a little chain
mail outfit yeah there was a little
onesie yeah i in my head because the way
it
it was in the bag and he folded it and
it tied it and it kind of looked like
rogue's head yeah we saw we saw a bunch
of chains a bunch of males little a
little that's why it was a little ring
so i thought like maybe he was making
him like a chain meal
suit which i and i didn't even go like
why would he do that never occurred to
me
that goku would get in that [ __ ]
empty bubble
and so it never occurred to me that like
you know
oh [ __ ] maybe
maybe he's maybe like
what's he gonna do give him this [ __ ]
suit of armor throw him in the [ __ ]
car and [ __ ] off until mandalorian
season three
i wonder why i don't think that he
reunites with grogo in this season how
could he not they keep pointing to it
i mean
i
it is already the height of oddness that
you drop shifted an entire episode of
your boba fett show to not show boba
fett at all it's not i love this story
did you say the height of hotness
because i absolutely agree oddness like
i love this episode it's the weirdest
it's the honest flex we're like we're
gonna make the best episode of the show
not at all about this show
it was kind of strange yes
um so for for it to not just give us one
episode about mandato and his quest he's
got to purify himself in the waters of
lake minnetonka and he's got to go back
and get grogu in order to be a
mandalorian again to then continue that
thread when boba fett is apparently
trying to take over the criminal
underworld and he needs muscle and den
is the muscle and there's going to be
you know same people revenge or whatever
else is happening to them keep telling
the growing story like part of me thinks
that that's that's just the promise for
what we're going to get in mando season
3 is the reunitement reunite meant
reunion of grogu and
it's always funny when your brain just
like drops a gear and you catch it i'm
all for [ __ ]
the reenactment
did you sneak in here for the
reenactment
i was going to say if it is a
best scar chainmail outfit lightsabers
can't cut bescar
do you think that's how grogu survives
kylo ren destroying luke's jedi like he
cuts everybody down but little grogu is
like
and you just can't get through him
so everybody who's worried about grog
loren
anakin or kylo ren
kylo ren in episode like before episode
7
destroys luke's jedi
academy and kills everybody
and everybody's been worried about grogu
like oh i hope i hope mando takes grogu
away so he doesn't die
by kylo ren's hand when he turns bad but
if he has a best scar chainmail suit i
don't think kylo ren could kill him
yeah but don't you think kylo ren would
have mentioned it in the movies like
there was a little yoda like guy wearing
chain mail and i just i could not kill
the [ __ ] out of him to save my life
he had a he had a magic hair shirt he
was like one of them mormons or
something like that and i couldn't his
magic pajamas completely stopped my
[ __ ] lightsaber and clearly then he's
the least resourceful person ever he's
like i'm doing whale in this dude
i could drown him maybe no that's not
gonna work i could bury him very very
tom and jerry to just do one thing over
here
um yeah i mean i i like i didn't even
think of what the repercussions would be
for the little outfit like i just
thought it was like oh he's making him
some clothes
but it sounds like they're loading them
up for like adventure
yeah
it's gonna carry a ring to the fires of
mount doom yeah
i i i'm in for that for some reason i
thought season three of mandalorian
wouldn't have any grogo in it but if
it's just like oh there's grosgu and now
he's got a chain meal
chain mail how's meal or mail mail
you've got chain mail
um
and they're back to back and they both
got sabers oh
baber and a lightsaber
back you know he's on he's on a couple
apple boxes so he could be on back to
back he's just floating
yeah
magic whatever
um i am uh yeah i know i enjoyed this
episode uh quite a bit as did most
people um we did get a bit of they they
brought boba back at the end not boba
fett but fennec shan
appears at the very end to to recruit
our man you know what i found
interesting too was like
his i like the way
favreau paces things i know some people
have been like complaining about boko
boba i'm not one of them i'm i'm there
for the whole ride
but i enjoy like the leisurely pace
which would with which he'll tell
a story like you know there's like felt
like five minutes
of the mandalorian catching a plane
essentially
and like you know oh weird why is he
flying commercial
it's crazy but i like the the whole like
i just like seeing that world
expanded somebody bullied me into
changing my hat but i really don't like
the black
come on man this is the look man
who's gonna take me seriously wearing
that hat this hat
you're gonna listen to every [ __ ]
word i say
um i like how he expands the universe
even something as goofy as like
oh if you're gonna
fly on a [ __ ] you know commercial
airline in their world the star wars
world which you've been in since you
were seven years old
uh here's how they take away your
weapons and how they store them and [ __ ]
like that i was like
way interested same way they do it at
walt disney world galactic star cruiser
seemed like a little bit of a commercial
to me
i thought that too where i was like i
wonder if these things are going to tie
in i was trying to listen for the name
to see what it is but one is
he was on a commercial flight that seems
like a southwest flight
delta you know because they have the
stewardess who was like making funny
jokes no i'm kidding and it's not
stewardess it's flight attendant um it
seemed like a commuter flight that he
was on whereas the galactic star cruiser
isn't that meant like you're [ __ ]
going on a cruise in space but
yeah
yeah i guess galactic star cruiser is
more like carnival cruise
yes
i think we figured it out there you go
um
but
the two things that i was like huh
was a the 10 minutes we just get to
watch them build a starship which
reminded me very much of iron man and
iron man one just like what are we doing
now hanging out in tony's lab building a
[ __ ] iron man suit there any bad guys
coming any drama nope just can this dude
build a suit it's like all right i get
it and amy sedaris makes all of that
just delicious and delightful and
[ __ ] java's on the side
cocktail jar with two at a time that was
pretty [ __ ] amazing where all of a
sudden you're like what did she say she
dated a jaw and then she keeps going
furry
yeah manscape missed out this week
yeah
all the fun we could have had with harry
jawas we'll give him a reference just
because we love him manscape.com kids
the harry john was there they know what
we're talking about
um yeah what a treasure she is
amy sedaris and like uh what fun she
brings to
to like all of her
scenes um
you know and not like
the most obvious choice in the world but
now you're like i'm so glad she's part
of this
universe like she's legit fun and funny
and
somebody who was telling me um luke in
our office said that
one of the little droids that she was
dealing with or talking to
is a droid from like one of the best
video games they ever made
uh
jc banff man do you have anything on
this bamf uh yeah it was from jedi
fallen order which everybody
loved
and that what's which robot that hangs
out with her
yeah the one with like the square face
with the two legs that has like kind of
inverted joints
yeah
so he was from a video game
well his his
i don't know if it's the same one
somebody was saying like maybe
just a model
like an r2 unit kind of thing
um jc i have i have a deep trivia
question that you may or may not know
the answer to
is that
long shaft
unit that they used
in in like they had to line it in
whatever they had nine names for it it's
a inverse projecting neutral coil or
whatever the [ __ ]
is that the same rod from the trash
compactor oh i thought that's what it
looked like when i was looking at it i
was like it looks like the rod they put
between the walls i bet you it is
because i saw
somebody
texted me an image of that thing
and was like how do they keep doing
things like this
um
so it has to be
yeah which is so deep cut
like who is this
who is sitting was that bryce dallas
howard who was like you know what would
be cool let's let's
give that thing that they used to brace
the trash compactor purpose
yes
or was that like felony
i don't think it's bryce dallas howard
that seems like it's scripted that seems
like i'm not taking anything away from
her but that seems
way too nerdy
for the guest director and then i know
she's like you know
connected to
the world
she's in the family directed before it's
in the family but
i think that's
favreau or filoni
like or or like art department you know
like production designers like you know
what would be cool what if it was this
and everybody said that's a [ __ ]
awesome idea let's do it
um i will say that i was less enamored
of
rebel alliance x-wing pilots as [ __ ]
traffic cops
you're going a little faster
it bugged me just because
i would like rebel alliance pilots to
have a more to do
even though the empire seems to be you
know haven't been dealt with
but not be [ __ ] asphalt cops
busting a dude for speeding in space
looking for his license and registration
like i don't know
you're what's wrong with the internet
you [ __ ] yeah
you you can't just [ __ ] it was a
quick scene there was no skin off your
ass why do you care it was cute i like
it and plus that dude came back the dude
from uh
from
kim's kim's
kim's
convenience
i used to be in new york old new york
yeah
i liked i like the fact i kind of like
that they're like
traffic cops they're like well
we beat the empire so somebody's got to
restore order to the galaxy i didn't
bump into that at all i mean you know of
course i respect your opinion but i
that didn't bum me out at all maybe
maybe it's just
i i have had enough experience with
shitty cops pulling me over for no
reason
that i didn't need the rebel alliance to
also suddenly be those guys too
you brought something personal to them
i brought my baggage which is fair and
you know bounce me if you want but that
does not that does not uh
get me to oh these are just good guys
hanging about just razzing a little bit
like oh god damn it
i liked when he uh you know [ __ ]
flipped the switch and was like
[Music]
i mean that's why that that beat exists
entirely it's for him to just dust them
and i get it all the flying stuff was
was really sweet they took us into
beggars canyon
have we ever been into beggars county do
they do it in the pod race they did it
in padres it looked it looked like the
almost the exact same
as the padres only it had been like
like urban sprawled into it a little bit
yeah i like
uh i like the x-wing pilot because he
comes into the bar and hangs out and
tweets about it
i feel like it gives us cred again for
personal reasons
personal reasons why i'm not that's
really bad
um it is uh i'm i'm having a good time
with it man like it's
i
my hat's off to those cats
and
i i'm like it it never once do i ever
sit there and go like man i wish i was
doing it it just makes me like a
seven-year-old again i'm so happy
to be
like
subject to somebody else's imagination
with these characters that i grew up
with my relationship to these characters
was always distant right they were
always up on a screen or some such [ __ ]
and never once do i go like oh i wish i
was on set for that
i wish they'd make them faster and i
wish people would spoil [ __ ] more for me
like i know a guy who makes the [ __ ]
show shoots it and he won't tell me [ __ ]
so that i wish i had and i would be in
the show in a heartbeat and [ __ ] but i
never like think about making it like
writing it or [ __ ] directing it like
directing it seems complicated but
writing it like i like what he's doing
like even the episodes of boba fett the
people were like boo
i i like the pace man it's so [ __ ]
leisurely and i've seen people like oh
it's such a formula he goes from one
town to another and does a thing i'm
like
and
like as long as they keep doing that and
make give me good star wars where i'm
like right on this is [ __ ] fun i know
a bunch of people got pissy about the
kids on the bike the mods and stuff
i
you know i'm like whatev that's fine
they didn't bump into it as hard as
others did that last episode though was
[ __ ] dope when we did the last
episode of fat man i i hadn't seen it
yet but
man that was [ __ ] dope but this
current episode of
boba fett aka the mandalorian
season 2b
um
was absolute [ __ ]
magic and
made me go like
what are they gonna do in [ __ ] season
three
i just they keep up in the ante i've
i like i love what they're doing it
makes me so [ __ ] happy dude
i watch that [ __ ] with my wife she
watches the show and she enjoys it like
we get to be kids again together
watching stars i didn't know her when
[ __ ] star wars came out when we were
kids
and this is like kind of the next best
thing man like where it's like you know
we're grown ass adults i'm 51 she's 50
and still
for like half hour 45 minutes it's like
wow
like that's cool like that's
i don't know it makes me feel young i
love it so much um but this episode was
just
dynamite
i agree
the um
bunch of people in chat calling out he
wasn't pulled over for speeding
it was his uh young clark kent superman
moment flying too close to the
southwest
commercial yeah yeah that's that's what
it was
also uh man
mark
[Laughter]
uh mandalorian says wizard like anakin
did like
like was kind of like the kid like so
cool
he said wizard which i i loved kind of
like i feel like it legitimizes episode
one using that word
well somebody just has to say laser
sword
yeah and that'll do that
what um
he didn't really wield the dark saber
that much in
the end of the mandalorian did he no
because he just kicked uh what's his
face's ass
and that's how he got it so this is the
first time we get to see him really
wield it then right yeah and the idea
that it gets heavier the more you use it
if you don't know how to use it well
like i've done
that like it's an enchanted sword that
has its own [ __ ] rules and he doesn't
know how to use it yet like that's kind
of fun and it cut his own leg with it i
know i let him just give him his way
because he could [ __ ] i'm gonna go down
this ladder now
and then he did and he gimped for a
while so he cut a fucker's head off in
this episode no yeah
brought to you by disney plus
alien dog-looking thing so they're like
you've got to [ __ ] it in
but if there's a human being forget it
yes i i love they kind of touched on
like a real deep cut
kind of expanded universe thing
was that only jedi could use lightsabers
because like a sword has a
counterbalance to it
so you don't cut your arm off or your
leg off because like a real heavy sword
has
like a pommel that balances it
whereas a lightsaber only jedi's can use
because they're more
hyper aware with the force so they don't
accidentally slice their head in half
and i liked in this episode that they
showed him using this
that because it's the weight is only in
the handle that he did slice himself
because it felt like a cool callback to
like oh this is why only jedi used that
type of thing
like it's not not to be used by amateurs
um
which for somebody who like read the
west end games role-playing book
you know 30 years ago i was like ha
you know i felt like leonardo dicaprio
and that meme pointing at the camera
going like
yeah exactly finn has a you see the
donut the jonah hill story that was
going around where he talked about like
leo was like you got to watch
mandalorian man watch it with me and he
[ __ ] made him watch it and he was
like
i don't know what the [ __ ] was going on
it was
it wasn't for me he kind of poo-pooed it
instead [ __ ] but the the fact that
leonardo dicaprio
was very into the mandalorian like made
me happy in some weird way
well i feel like it came right on the
heels of that um that fake story about
i'm sure you saw it about that the girl
who went on her worst date ever was with
leonardo dicaprio when he rented out a
movie theater and made her watch all
nine star wars movies in a row while he
ran up and down the islands with a
lightsaber acting it out
that was not that that was a fake story
i never even heard that story but it was
untrue yeah it was it was you know made
up by a by a satire site but it took up
a lot of it it picked up some speech
steam online because
suddenly it was how dare this woman not
think this was the best date ever
but you know clearly it's one of those
it's a lie that's just close enough to
the truth to work that leo's a [ __ ]
star wars fan because why would he not
be
he's that's the thing i've never but if
you were a fan don't you want to be in
it like this is a guy who could call
them up and be like let me be in it
i mean i guess except
you know
suddenly then it becomes is that
leonardo dicaprio and jedi robes
that's weird like it starts to pierce
the illusion
when you suddenly get [ __ ]
jack dawson
i say worth it it reminds me of a
director i know who said i don't ever
want to do an episode of the mandalorian
even though he knows the show runner and
the dp
on the show
maybe i just want to watch this
that would be my bigger thing i'd be
like if they were ever like we want you
to come where i'd be like can i be in it
so like in your episode i'm like in a
better episode
like a better director who else you got
coming on it's like i'll counter your
offer with you direct it i'll just be in
it like that's going to yeah about that
but i wouldn't even like back in the day
i would imagine young kev smith would be
like oh i want to write it but i don't i
don't ever want to write the show like
as i watch it i'm like i like exactly
what he's doing
i like the pace of the story he's
telling the only thing i don't like
about mandalorian is having to wait
every week but there's also something
nice about that
you know there's there's some lesson and
discipline there
i think that similarly would be
nostalgic like that's why i kind of dig
it which is this is the way i i
in took television information for the
bulk of my life was i gotta wait a week
to get it
he's exactly right kids it does it takes
me back where it's like
they're gonna make me wait
and i had no choice but to wait back in
the day yeah it's like oh [ __ ] is
[ __ ] garth knight really gonna kill
michael knight
i gotta tune in not just next week but
maybe that's the season cliffhanger so i
gotta wait like five months
before this [ __ ] pops off come on
is fonzie going to make it over the
chicken stand
or the shark pool
not a shark well that good
that became such a pop cultural
reference later on in life as we all
know jumped the shark but for like 10 15
maybe 20 years
prior to it becoming a
thing
it was literally just something that
happened in happy days that a lot of
people talked
about right up until indiana jones four
and then nuke the fridge took over i
took over yeah i remember that
um yeah boba fett booga boba fett how
many more episodes left bamf man
two
seven total you get two more
fair enough
well i i i gotta imagine we're gonna see
grogu in one of them
i still don't think so i mean at this
point i hope so
i i will put i will put money on it i'll
bet you a crisp 20 bill
that we get no grogu
i'll take that bet
and we will pay that bet off in the
cantina
um when next we managed to together
i'll take that bet
you um i'll tell a quick story here you
mentioned laser sword so we have a tap
handle at the bar
that uh that is a lightsaber handle that
you pull it and it lights up and um when
we first put it on
we had this
this like almost like simpsons android
dungeon comic book shop guy come in and
he's like i would like the beer
from the lightsaber tap handle
and i said well this
you mean the laser sword
and he goes
this is a star wars bar
and that is called a lightsaber in star
wars not a laser sword i was like well i
own the bar i would know
the theme of this bar
and in this bar it's called a laser
sword and he's like well then it's has
nothing to do with star wars i go
unless you've seen star wars episode one
where anakin refers to it as qui-gon's
laser sword
and uh he threw his hands up and he left
he was so frustrated that
reference to discount his
uh his lightsaber demands
i love how proud jc is of not making
money on that customer
and the guy's probably like finally a
bar that i can drink at
where i feel welcome me star wars nerd
and then he meets an even nerdier star
wars
who then drives him from the bar with
his nerdy knowledge
i'll just go to [ __ ] bennigan's i
don't give a [ __ ]
have you watched encanto by any chance i
have yes
do you like it somebody in chat was like
why aren't you guys talking about
encanto um i think it's lovely i think
it's lovely i um they say it's almost
super powers it's about a a family the
material family in colombia um
i believe it's colombia i think it's
columbia um who all have sort of each
each child with this family has a
magical gift like there's one you know
daughter who's super strong
there's one who can sort of see into the
future
another you know daughter who can like
make things grow out of her hands but
it's very much like the x-mansion but it
was also in the middle of columbia and
they sang a lot of lin-manuel miranda
songs
um but it follows the one daughter who
has no gift and what it's like to to
live in a family of ultimately mutants
but not be the one to also get their
superpower
it's super it's gorgeous i mean it's
[ __ ] disney um the songs are great
the performances are great the story
that it tells is great um it almost made
my top 10. it was one of those like just
off the podium
um numbers um
that i was going to talk about later
when we got to talk about my top 10 for
2021 um but might as well do it now [ __ ]
it you you got what you wanted chad
i think it's terrific if you haven't
seen it see it
uh
let's talk about that's it for for
for uh boba and encanto let's talk about
but i will watch encanto now let's talk
about peacemaker which i have not
watched episode five did you watch it i
did watch it today
it's good enough to spoil in it
um you know it's it's funny it's it's
not it's not as
deep an episode as episode 4 was
you know
the the vigilante in prison just beating
up white supremacists and the reasons
why and and peacemakers issues with his
father like that all felt very
you know
it felt very sticky it felt very much
like we're getting messy with these
characters in a great way this episode
was less that this episode was we got a
mission to go on and it's going to be
brutal and violent and funny and
all those things but it wasn't it wasn't
some like super deep character episode
um a
very cool plot development happens by
the end that you know won't spoil if you
haven't seen it yet um but i do like how
um the the opposite of your love for the
leisurely pace
of the book of boba
peacemaker is burning through story
peacemaker is like
this person's a butterfly that person is
a butterfly this person's going to find
out about that person and this person's
in jail and like all of these these
cards start getting turned very very
quickly
and another big one gets turned here in
episode five so how many episodes is
uh peacemaker um i don't i think it's
eight
i think it's eight
but i'm not entirely sure i look forward
to it uh i was uh told by my wife that i
could not watch it without her so i have
not watched this episode yet
but i can't wait to watch it is one of
my favorite shows it's on at the moment
man
now that now that the yellow jackets is
over my god did you watch yellow jackets
i have not i'm i'm a bad tv watcher i
know
uh my old lady i shouldn't say that my
young lady wife um was uh talking about
a show on netflix that she wanted me to
ask mark
if mark had seen it because she watched
she binged it and like [ __ ] loved it
uh it is called what archive archive 81
archive 81 but mark hadn't seen it no
i'm i'm like there's
there are about so many hours in the day
and
you know it's one of those like i'm
gonna watch these couple things with my
wife and who watch these couple things
by myself i'm gonna do the work that
needs doing
and sadly it's not leaving me as much
time as i would hope
for
the [ __ ] that i know that i should watch
i uh have been in writer mode as well
um
uh
for stuff i'm doing for me but also
like uh you know stuff i've been hired
to do uh so that eats up a lot of time
doesn't give you time to
like indulge as quickly i was able to
watch boko boba because um
i got up like way
early like two three in the morning and
they dropped the episode and i was like
you know what
i'm up so i'll smoke and watch
but most of the time i've been working
on a
thing that i can't talk about and
another thing
that i can't talk about
yeah sorry again
then there is that we got notes on a
third thing
that i can't talk about
um
so i've been
on a thing but
working on things is fed by all the
things that we generally watch
um because it becomes very shorthand i i
can't write
like favreau where it's just like you
know
in this scene nobody says anything like
that would drive me nuts
but
structure
and like ending of episodes you know how
to go out how to make them want to tune
in for the next one and stuff
that's
that's all been like on my mind as i
work on these things that i'm working on
and all that stuff's very helpful
yeah no it's always good
to
to
to intake
this stuff and see like i don't see what
that guy's doing i want to see how they
pull this off i want to see how they
made me feel this way or how they
executed this particular plot beat it's
all research
uh you know what i've been watching
obsessively though for the last week uh
because i wanted to show my wife i was
like watch this and you tell me if you
think this looks [ __ ] cool
is that moon knight trailer
that [ __ ] i you know what i feel i'm
getting the vibes of it feels like
marvel's fight club
in as much as like remember he had the
divergent personality
it feels like that vibe as i watched the
trailer again because we just rewatched
fight club the other night which by the
way
[ __ ] holds up man
like
his movie's from 1999 and it really
holds up
over everything's [ __ ] such a great
flick
um but i was watching that going like
wait no and then i that's when after we
watched that i was like i gotta show you
this moon night trailer
um and um
i i'm [ __ ] in dude
i keep pausing i was pausing it to go on
that's kanchu
and she was like who's that i'm like
that's [ __ ]
that's kanchu man
that's the egyptian god of the of the
the moon the knight like he gives him
his powers man i'm conscious
i need you you know kanchu and she was
like i don't know what you're talking
about
but when by the time the trailer was
done she was like this looks [ __ ]
dope
it does man [ __ ]
when's that hack coming out march
i don't recall but i think so
spring
can't wait
um all right uh boba fett's out now
uh
peacemakers out peacemaker's out now
uh a bunch of people blowing up about
encanto they're like watch it [ __ ]
i'm like i will i swear i'll do it
good lord
um
so and is that all of our upfront review
stuff yeah i mean we could we could
bounce right into news um we could do
the top 10 of 2021
um
whichever order you'd like to do
trying to think i watched a movie this
week but what movie was it
oh it wasn't very it was boring all
right let's let's let's do uh
the let's do your list
okay
um
this is your top 10 of the 20. of 2021
top 10 kids strap in because mr mark
bernard and he's going to give you his
top 10
of 2021 yes we're in 2022 and yes
2021 is the past but old men like me and
mark we live in the past we live for the
past so
begrudge him as he tells you his
favorite movies of 2021 did the list
change since you were originally going
to do it
um it did
it did it changed by like two or three
things
um the most recent addition to the list
was
writers of justice which we had talked
about um
love that movie yeah
um but yeah it's not i mean it's a
little bit late in the
it's not 2021 anymore but we're in
awards season where nominations started
to come out the oscars will come out
pretty soon we won't see the officers
until march and all the movies in 2021
so contenders as they call them mark
contenders
have you [ __ ] seen how thick
entertainment weekly is now well it's
monthly now it's not weekly anymore
and yet it's still called entertainment
weekly it is yeah weird huh what kind of
[ __ ] conundrum is that
that's
yeah it's awards season so actually i
bet you a lot of your
picks are going to be relevant to awards
season i think they will be
so the the just off the podium the the
three movies that didn't make the top 10
cut encanto one of them um another
disney movie luca
pixar which i liked quite a bit
um
and the beatles get back
which you know was released on disney
plus kind of as a tv thing but it's
really a six hour documentary
about the beatles you know i think we've
talked about it on the show but it is as
as uh incisive
a document of the creation of art
as i've seen in a while as well as this
really interesting look at people for
whom
we have viewed as pop culture gods for
so long that we may or may not have
forgotten that they were just kids
you know like at this point in their
lives they're all in their late 20s you
know maybe early 30s you know and
they've been famous for
i don't know a third of their lives
and you know but they're also still just
people just you know having weird
[ __ ] relationships with each other
you know falling in love not in love you
know
don't know what they're going to do next
hungry thirsty all the [ __ ] that regular
human people do they just happen to be
the most famous people in the world
um if you haven't seen it and you're in
any way at beale's fan um run and go see
it even the most casual beatles fan will
get something out of it
um
so number ten all right this is the
official list man that's [ __ ] that
wasn't even good enough to make the top
ten yes here comes mark with the top ten
in descending order man to build your
anticipation my nipples are hard let's
listen in number ten number ten tragedy
macbeth
denzel washington francis mcdormand joel
absolutely love this movie it's so good
so good
um you know it again like shakespeare
can be a barrier for some people and i
100 get that it's a barrier for me all
the time as well but this is one of the
most accessible versions of shakespeare
that i've seen
and it helps that it has
some of the greatest greatest actors of
our time
doing it who are not necessarily
shakespeareans
um but still have the chops and so yeah
it's 100 worth watching gorgeous
moving
you know it's [ __ ] the scottish play
so
um insanely well composed uh and staged
um reimagined
um the uh
10 i bumped because i was like wow
that's number 10. you liked nine things
better than that
um i did i did can't wait to hear what
they are because that was [ __ ] good
man i was gripped like we popped it on i
was like oh watch a few minutes if it's
boring we can turn it off and the whole
time i was this
oh my god it's glorious black and white
um i absolutely i love that movie uh it
did belong if i had a top 10 it
definitely been it but i imagine it
would be higher on mine but i'm now it
makes me so curious to hear
nine through one or what's number nine
number nine is nightmare alley guillermo
del toro's sort of remake of what seems
to be like a 1940s film noir about like
carny freaks and
and con men and mentalism and all of it
i'm glad to know that you
you like this too i found this movie
crazy haunting yeah
yeah stuck with me more than most movies
did
uh this year in fact film school fridays
the new podcast i do tomorrow's episode
is about nightmare alley
like i thought it was really terrific i
thought it was really
you know it's it's an odd movie
in 2021
because it is
resolutely not cheery in any way
it's a film noir and if you know how
film noirs work your hero does not
usually come out ahead and a remake too
and a remake you know i mean i think
it's based on the original book
um but even still just like bradley
cooper's doing good work kate blanchet
is doing good work
um rooney mara is doing really good work
but more than that it's just you know
gail del toro's
vision of what circus life is like
you know his vision of what the 40s were
like you know and it's
it's you know if i had one bump on this
movie which is maybe why it's not higher
on this list for me
is that it still retains this vision
that the 1940s um didn't have any people
of color in it
and whatever city that they're in which
i think is supposed to be chicago um
that it's still quite as lilly white as
it is it just it doesn't quite feel as
real to me but it's it's a relatively
minor bump which is why it's still in my
top ten because [ __ ] guillermo can
make a [ __ ] movie
yeah oh he's very [ __ ] gifted that
guillermo del toro um he uh
he's releasing a 500 or a thousand
print run black and white version of the
movie like this weekend yeah i think
it's in theaters so like you could
see it in black and white i saw it in
color
but in retrospect i wish like i had seen
it in black and white cho'grin who's the
guest on tomorrow's uh
uh
film school fridays he saw the black and
white version said it was [ __ ]
beautiful
so i might actually i honestly after i
watched
um nightmare alley i was like i always
want to call it damnation alley but
that's a completely different movie
after i watched nightmare alley i was
like i will i loved it i admire the [ __ ]
out of it but i'll never need to watch
that again in my entire life
and now
i do actually want to see it again in
black and white like yeah
yeah like i remember they did that with
uh with mad max for europe they put out
i guess it was on the the video release
the blood and chrome edition which was
just black and white and it's again like
[ __ ] gorgeous because
those guys know how to make movies
so yeah that's number nine number eight
writers of justice which we talked about
not too long ago can't [ __ ] say
enough good things about a hundred times
where was it hulu or amazon where was
that
it was on here let's get down kids what
country is that [ __ ] from that is from
denmark i believe oh
what a [ __ ] watch this movie was man
mads mikkelsen
um is just uh
brutally uh darkly wonderful in it but
the story itself
was uh i hadn't seen it before and i'm
not a math person i hate math and
it's a math movie that like really
[ __ ]
you know is a lot more pulse
pounding than a beautiful mind let's
just leave it there
yes it is it is closer to the punisher
than a beautiful mind as far as math
movies go um yeah that's number eight
number seven shang chi and the legend of
the ten rings
that's number seven that's number seven
i had a great time at xiang chi um it's
a superhero that i was not intimately
familiar with from my marvel reading
days it was never my jam
but you know what they did with the
character casting sumi liu at the lead
he is so charming and so endearing um
and the martial arts is top notch
and it's a really great family story um
both about the family you're born with
and then the family that you you make
along the way
um
so yes
number seven
number six might make my list as well
but i think it would be lower down
probably if it got in there it would
squeak in at 10.
number 76 judas and the black messiah
is that this year was g that was
february of this year
was it up for oscars last year
um
i think it was maybe it was maybe maybe
the beatles mix it on the list after all
right because daniel kahlua was
nominated but it got its wide release in
february that's how you got its wide
release later on yeah like it did an
oscar qualifying run before the end of
the year but mostly came out in 2020.
then never mind [ __ ] you judas
it won oh and chapter saying it won best
screenplay last year yeah it did
um so never mind
my fact checking was erroneous so slide
everything up beatles is number ten
macbeth at nine nightmare only at eight
writer's versus seven seanchi at six
encantos in the wings going maybe he'll
[ __ ] up again and we make the list
how do i get in this [ __ ] list
um
number five is mitchell's the mitchells
versus the machines
oh my god i haven't watched this but
i've seen the billboards all over town
pushing it for awards and it's from the
spider-man into the spider-verse guys
right miller and lord um who gave us 20
jump street into the spider-verse
um and it's fantastic it is it's this
animated movie that netflix put out
about this incredibly dysfunctional
family that needs to survive a robot
uprising um
and it's just wonderful it's funny and
it's sweet and the action is great
um
i i then the voice work is great
it's i can't i can't speak highly enough
about this movie i watch it on a lark
where the [ __ ] was i i was in
texas visiting colleges with my son
and we just one night at the hotel which
is like what should we watch and then
boom boom boom let's do this and we both
just fell in love with it you know and
it's it's also got that thing where by
the end of it you know you're crying a
little bit in a way that your kid
doesn't quite understand because he's
still you know a teenager but he was a
parent they're like this is amazing
so
it's a netflix movie it's a netflix
movie yeah
so what's that done uh nightmare alley
is going to be on i think hbo max on
february 1st
so if people haven't had a chance to go
out and see it and based on the box
office numbers
it did like kevin smith business so like
a lot of people did not get to go see it
um you're gonna be able to watch it at
home indeed i mean everything just don't
make it you're like it's friday night i
got me some haagen-dazs got me some
snacks let's watch nightmare alley kids
because you will be like [ __ ] it'll
[ __ ] with your head
yeah watch it during the day
you're gonna need some hours to get over
this after it's all done yeah okay
uh number four
spiderman no way home
you know we have talked at great length
about spider-man no way home for all the
reasons we like it um
you know i
i had issues with the kind of mushy
middle section of it but the beginning
of it is fantastic and the end of it is
a [ __ ] home run
like it ties up so many different
threads it lands so many different
planes and most of them are emotional
and that at the end of the day is kind
of what you want out of a movie like
that
they're running that for oscar's pretty
hardcore i saw the [ __ ] three
spider-man do an interview yeah and uh
somebody my wife was like you got a
digital screener of spider-man i was
like the [ __ ]
so they're uh they're pushing it they're
starting it yeah and i know the
screenplay is out there i think they're
gonna be pushing for that but yeah i
mean i i for all of my misgivings about
it the experience of watching it just
made me feel good
it was bliss it was absolute bliss
indeed
um number three is a documentary
a documentary made by a first-time
filmmaker
by the name of amira thompson
you may know him better as quest love
the drummer oh
oh my god what's what is quest love's
real name amir thompson never knew that
uh summer of seoul summer
which you know how does this not get
nominated for the academy awards
i mean it's it's a it's a great [ __ ]
movie um it's about a a collection a
series of concerts that took place in
harlem in 1969
um that had been lost
to history until two years ago when
somebody found the reels of footage in
her basement
and it's reels of footage including like
stevie wonder and nina simone and slime
the family stone all performing in an
outdoor park in harlem
and it's just ecstatic you know it's
it's this this really joyous experience
of music that's great
at a time when the world was changing
you know in lots of ways not the least
of which are you know we're putting men
on the moon you know woodstock is
happening civil rights movement is
happening you know and and here's this
this sort of celebration of black
culture
um
that that deserved to have been
remembered
and
the fact that it finally got its chance
is is wonderful and yeah it's it's
joyous i think it's also on hulu it has
a theatrical run but i think now you can
watch it on the summer of song i'm so
happy for uh for him i also know like uh
david dinner scene i think is one of the
producers but uh quest love's such a
wonderful guy and uh
and uh i know the documentary meant a
bunch to him and stuff and i've been
watching yet but everybody loves it but
i'm gonna watch it now you say it's on
hulu yeah yeah
it's fantastic
i'm in um
number two
for me was a bit you know it's
at some point
movies become emotional you know and
you're and you're feeling about them and
you're you're ranking it even internally
in your brain is how did you how did it
make you feel when you watched it
and
uh my my family had rented out a theater
in june
for father's day
um so that we could go see in the
heights on the big screen
and i like wept through the entire movie
now some of it is because
it i was back in the theater some of it
is because it was father's day and i was
already emotionally compromised but then
someone's because this movie is just
incredibly vibrant and joyous and the
music is great and i love the broadway
show and i'm a lin-manuel miranda fan
and so all of these things put in the
same pot um
just yielded this this really kind of
transcended movie-going experience for
me and i'm not even a musicals fan
but this is just gorgeous even my son
who hates musicals was like no this is
great
and uh and yeah some of it is is the
time in the place but i think it's it's
a gorgeous movie um
that that has quite a bit to say
about the time that we're living in
while also having [ __ ] banning music
numbers um
that's number two that's number two
in the heights in the heights
that leaves one spot left kids uh before
we see that top spot
just to let cats know and chat i'm not
stoned
i'm being quiet because i made a promise
that i was gonna let mark talk this year
so just because i'm like quiet don't
mean i'm stoned i don't get stoned i'm a
51 year old man like
i get centered
[Laughter]
teenagers get stoned um so no i'm not
stoned i'm just trying to
[ __ ] let them talk for god's sakes
man this is such a fickle audience
uh so number one all the little kids in
springfield are sobs there except just
like gabo
[Laughter]
all right number one we get to find out
what's number one on mark's top 10 list
of 2021
watch it be a movie that came out in
2020.
2018
greatest hit
uh mark loved avatar yes that's right
are you familiar with this matrix movie
no no the first matrix
oh my god is
is matrix going to be your number one oh
no
no it isn't did you see it i did
well
before we jump to number one which is
probably gonna be all glory and [ __ ] and
i bet you i can guess what it is
do you have a little side shade for
matrix resurrection i i
i feel like there was
there were these two competing
impulses
on the part of
lana wachowski which was i do kind of
want to continue this story and i love
canner reeves and i love carrion and moz
i love these two characters only give
them a chance for real romance
and you know when that movie does
indulge in that
in that choice it's actually really
lovely
and then the other one is i want to burn
the corpse and salt the earth so that
nobody can ever make another matrix
movie and so here's my version of that
which is take everything that you
thought you loved about it
invert it
and
bury it up its own ass and then just
have it kind of comment on itself in
ways that don't
translate to entertainment
i didn't like this movie
for a bunch of different reasons
but nonetheless of which is it like all
of the things that were cool about the
matrix it went the opposite way
like canner reeves can be kung fu and
now what does he do he force pushes
things away
you know like what do we hate about the
matrix reloaded the 20 minute just
download from the bad guy explaining
[ __ ] now we get two of those
um
just man i just
no
no
no
you know like there was even a moment
where you know the movie
wants you to think
that neo thomas anderson is torn between
understanding or believing that the
world he's living in israel and the
world of the matrix was real and to do
that as a kind of ongoing push and pull
about a guy not sure about the fabric of
reality is interesting except that the
movie tells you from the very first
scene that the matrix is a real place
by having characters who are in that
matrix pushing to the real world and
like oh well then you took all the
suspense of us wondering if maybe those
first two three movies were just video
games if they were just imagination
were those the the the ravings of a of a
mind losing its grasp on the truth
that'd been cool didn't go that way
instead
it went this way so no i was not a fan
of the matrix resurrections i wanted to
be
nobody was more in the bag for this
movie than i was but
it uh it just didn't not just deliver me
what i wanted but deliver a thing unto
itself that made
sense
well if that that means that your number
one slot if it's not matrix revolut
resurrections
it can only be one other movie let's
hear it
if you walk with that rhythm
you won't attract the worms kevin i knew
it i knew it
i knew it i could have called this like
months ago
pointed at the bleachers
now
i was there when you watched this
picture yes the first time it has a it
must have grown on you substantially
because you liked it well enough when we
first saw it but i did not get the
impression that you were like that's my
favorite movie of the year how did we
get there it took it took the second
viewing
um
for me because again like i came to it
as we talked about it both in the room
and on the podcast as a fan of both the
books and the david lynch
and so the first time i saw it it was a
comparison viewing like how does this
stack up to the other versions of it
that i know
and you know not to say that i found it
wanting it just
it
didn't i couldn't take it on its own
terms at that moment the second time i
saw it was oh [ __ ] i see all the things
that he's doing now i see all of the the
sort of intuitive leaps that he's making
i see the choices that he's making and
the design work remains amazing and and
chalamet is doing some stuff with it
like i still have
problems with how it ends
because it doesn't for me promise quite
the
the story that i know is coming
but given that we are 100 getting the
second half of that movie
um
i think i think it's masterful um and i
think it's emotional um ultimately which
was you know always the issue with the
david lynch version was that it was very
sterile
um
but i think that this is this is digging
deeper into paula tradies and uh and i
love it and i love it
shy elude man [ __ ]
i never would have guessed it um yet
i completely knew it
uh there it is mark's top 10 list for
2021 kids
some people have asked do you have one
no
some of my some of what he said would
have been on mine
um
but you know
yeah and there's some stuff that i
haven't seen so like i haven't seen
don't look up yet i haven't seen sereno
i haven't seen titan
to
um i haven't seen tender bar like
there's there's a handful of sort of
oscar in the least that i haven't seen
pig
which i've heard is great
um so you know to a certain degree don't
take omission for
for uh
you know a lack of uh
appreciation
just at some point it's i got some
there's some holes in that
the things i saw i like those the most
there it is kids mr mark bernard brought
you quality
quality separating the wheat from the
chaff
kisses kiss his feet you son of a [ __ ]
he brought you quality
[Laughter]
um all right uh we i guess we should get
to the news is there any park there's a
there's a handful of news out there my
friend let's throw that handful of news
in my face man like so much
[ __ ] salt in the middle of a fight
where i'm like ah and then punch me in
the gut with news
um
there there were two things that broke
today that i was not really going to
talk about i take that back i want to do
take two all right go for it throw that
in my face like you're migs
in the [ __ ] cell block and i'm
chloe starling and then [ __ ] you know
lectures like hey john starlight agents
dollar come back and he's like i would
never have that happen to you man he was
so pissed off that that dude whipped [ __ ]
at her that's when i knew he was a
gentleman
so in this scenario
you're the one getting [ __ ] within his
face i'm chloe starling you're migs
okay multiple migs i wasn't sure he
could get it going again this quickly
but multiple things well remembered well
uh what news we got um so yeah there
were two things that broke today which
are kind of personality based news less
things that are happening
the first was weird
in that uh there's a ezra miller
recorded like what seemed to be a tick
tock or
some kind of video that began to spread
virally
where he's calling out the klu klux klan
a very specific chapter of the ku klux
klan
um
basically it's come at me bro i'm ezra
miller you know what you're doing oh hey
um
so yeah it's
she's listening dude she's way
she'll have an opinion on tick-tock
stuff she's got her own tick-tock and no
she doesn't she doesn't yet why why did
he do this what's this i mean look wait
nobody likes the clan but why is he
against this particular clan chapter uh
it's unclear like he offered no
specifics whatsoever and and so far
the internet has not um clarified what
that is but
i mean
it's ezra it's the flash versus the kkk
which is a is an interesting way to
promote a movie um i mean hey i'm all
for going up against the kkk i just
didn't quite expect ezra miller to be
the soldier of this particular moment
but okay cool
um
the other thing was evangeline lilly
has i guess outed herself as an
anti-vaxxer
um
she went to a rally in dc
uh i think over last weekend or recently
wait wait an auntie masker
she's an anti-massacre and an
anti-baxter she doesn't remember when
she got in trouble for the mask stuff
there were you know because people were
like shut the [ __ ] up or else they're
gonna kick you out of the
quadrafini what is it quantum mania yeah
um
but uh i you know and then she
if i remember correctly she kind of
backtracked and was like
hey perhaps i'm wrong or something like
that but i did not hear that she was
anti-vaxx as well you know i think she's
mostly anti-mandate
but
because you know the government
shouldn't be able to force you to put
things in your body
which okay but again that has never
really been the position of the
government it's just been if you want to
have access to certain goods and
services
um then we would require you to be
vaccinated if you don't want those
services then by all means go about your
life and be happy if you can
hey banff man jump in here real quick
and
tell us if chatted lighting up with
people
having opinions
uh now we're we're safe so far we're
okay so far
as soon as i say that
it will happen
um
how uh i mean look at her stance is her
stance and
this is what i'll say i'm not gonna
here i'm double vaxxed and boosted
and if i could get another booster i'd
[ __ ]
i'd get more if i could
so that's where i stand and [ __ ]
um
i
also you know
don't work for a major corporation i
mean i guess like lions lions get us
clerks three but i don't work for them
this is a somebody who works for like
disney
do you think they're pleased with this
turn of events
i can't imagine they are
but
freedom of speech
absolutely
um and then the last thing you know
really quickly up top is that a
tennessee school board voted to drop
the pulitzer prize-winning graphic novel
mouse i saw this this morning uh based
on something that i'm like
one of them was nudity
and i had to really think hard back to
my [ __ ] mouse reading days to
remember
if there was any nudity and if there is
it certainly is not suggestive nudity
it's horrifying there's a community in
schindler's list because
people were brutalized in almost every
way you could brutalize people
and uh and so
yeah i don't i don't i don't understand
the criticisms of it other than it seems
like there was one dude who read it and
didn't like it
and didn't understand why that needed to
be the way we were teaching the
holocaust
the [ __ ] is wrong with people
guy like that same kind of guy that's
like why the rebel x-wings got to be the
cops in this galaxy
[Laughter]
okay
picayune
trying to find fault and everything um
why why do people why why mark why are
people like that uh i'm i'm i'm not
entirely sure other than small-minded
ignorant um neil gaiman um had i think
which is my favorite quote about it he
said there's only one kind of people who
would vote to ban mouse whatever they're
calling themselves these days
god point honestly that's the first
thing i thought of when i saw that story
this morning i'm like
the only reason to come out against this
book is if
you come out against this book
on a regular basis when it's not this
book
yeah
don't matter how it's disguised you just
come out against that
yeah it seems weird man
because there's nothing offensive about
it but you're talking about a
a multiple award-winning book what does
it win [ __ ] pulitzer
private everything a book could win it's
one
and this is like the book that like you
know you know comic books of course now
are enjoying uh
incredible reputational rise based on
the multi-billion dollar movies they're
making out of these franchises but
believe it or not kids let me take you
back to the early 90s
and beyond
when uh maybe the late 90s
when uh you know the comic book business
was hurting really real really bad and
stuff and
marvel particularly had stock that was
like worth a penny or something like
that one thing you could always count on
is the stellar reputation of
mouse
they would write about it in the new
york times in time magazine all smart
people would talk about it then they
talked about the watchmen as well alan
moore's watchman
um these were the like books that
legitimized
comic books in the eyes of the
mainstream like oh well common because
there's so many articles i've read over
the course of my life well
based on mouse alone comics aren't just
for kids anymore are they
meet mouse and [ __ ] like that so
this book's been around for damn near
[ __ ] 35-40 years
yeah
who the [ __ ] wants to quote-unquote
cancel that book now how is that book
in any way shape or form a detriment to
education
you know i think this
as as we're beginning to see
the arguments against you know critical
race theory
were less about critical race theory and
more about the people who wrote
books that could be considered
any way or shape to do with race and so
then it became an assault on books by
black authors on books by latinx authors
by books by
anybody who wasn't just straight up a
white person
and i think mouse is getting caught up
in that which is we don't like this we
don't like what it says we don't like
what it says about these particular
people i.e nazis and we don't like the
way it says it and so now we've decided
we don't want this book anymore we don't
want to be challenged by our literature
we just want the literature we like
and it's it's a slippery slope
once you decide
to legislate
the ability to ban a book because you
don't like it
uh sir davey sockrocker says america
isn't one country we're barely 50
connected states
it's not wrong
yeah a lot of different different
countries going on within this country
indeed
um
well i don't want to live in the country
that doesn't [ __ ] let mouse be on
their shelves come on man
it's [ __ ] this book is educational
more than anything else yeah and also
it's really good yeah it's insanely well
done it's a beautiful book too
graphically just beautiful art
spiegelman and you know now people are
like well you know maybe nowadays people
are like
oh big deal but like this was a
breakthrough [ __ ] book man and like
brought real legitimacy to the comic
book field
and respect you know it
just ridiculous uh you know i'm going to
borrow a line from goodwill hunting a
movie i did not write but was a
co-executive producer on or some
co-associate producer on or whatever the
[ __ ]
um
[ __ ] people baffle me
i'll use another line more familiar
how about dem apples that that's that's
for the
populists out there indeed i was going
deep cuts mark it was a good deep cut
thank you
line one of my favorite lines in cinema
history because it [ __ ] is applicable
every day as as as applicable now as it
was in
1997 when the movie came out
and won an academy award i might add
indeed
um so moving on to uh to less
potentially polarizing news and two
things that we can all just celebrate is
on the horizon namely
james gunn is prepping another suicide
squad spin-off television show
what yes did he say what uh he did not
say what his quote is we're working on
something else now another tv show
that's connected to that universe he
told deadline i can't quite say
um
he's busy my god that guy can multitask
it's nuts he was remember i interviewed
him last week we still haven't put that
[ __ ] clip up
um of the long interview
um but he he was you know promoting
[ __ ] uh peacemaker and he was
working on guardians three or the
christmas special whichever one comes
first yeah i think it's guardians three
that he's on the set of um he talked
about a little bit about the season two
of peacemaker um which has yet to be
officially greenlit but according to him
there's a really good chance that it
will be
um because they're the biggest show in
the world right now
um you know he continued speaking on the
set of guardians three in atlanta
i wonder if it's dave
that would be my guess the small chin
polka dot man series poke about man
series disney spoilers didn't he die at
the end of suicide squad
um he did but there's no reason it
couldn't be a prequel series
um yeah so he he
should do anything man he's [ __ ]
wonderful [ __ ] yeah
according to sources gun has approached
hbo max with the idea for another series
built around another one of the
characters in suicide squad the project
is in the embryonic stages with nothing
written or greenlit but hbo max is said
to be high on it based on gun's
enthusiasm for the idea
um he would not confirm nor deny that
it's uh blood support played by dr selba
or harley quinn played by margot robbie
um but it seems that the fact that those
two are honking movie stars they might
not be able to squeeze a tv series in
um
you know all he says is i can't say
anything it's connected to the universe
i don't think it will be the same genre
as peacemaker it won't be as much a
comedy as peacemaker but it will be in
the same universe which i think does
give some credence to the potential of a
polka dot man show
because that doesn't feel like it would
be a comedy but it could also be um
just really [ __ ] good
because i'd watch this mulch and do just
about anything
me as well
um
all right
that's good news
cool
um today
arnold schwarzenegger
tweeted and instagramed a picture of
himself
a movie poster for a film that may or
may not be called zeus
with him playing the titular greek god
and the dateline is february
now i don't know if this is a movie if
it's a tv show if it's a [ __ ]
commercial for the super bowl to sell i
don't know
car batteries or whatever
but
it is giving me the big king conan vibes
we always wanted like buff [ __ ] 70
year old long schwarzenegger with a gray
ass beard
as a badass elder warrior person
all i'm saying is i'm [ __ ] here for
schwarzenegger as the god of thunder do
they mean this february like next week
or next february
um unclear there was never a date on it
was just february now whether that's an
announcement or a drop
like [ __ ] we're putting it on netflix
here you go
i don't know but it it titillated me
i was titillated
um in chat somebody suggested uh
los angeles catfish said uh super bowl
spot maybe
very i mean it's definitely on the table
or whether it's just
see that john ham
apple spot
so [ __ ] good so charming man he's a
that dude
yeah make him a batman
i'm not saying make him the batman but
like they're making more than one batman
movie now so
i do
[ __ ] cape man he's a he just looks
like an action figure
and he's funny too put him in peacemaker
heed my advice hollywood look at my
career i know wherever i speak
he's a smartie
james gunn is like i'm doing fine
without your
advice kev thank you kevin yeah we're
okay
um apple
has decided to make a godzilla
television show
okay
apple tv is partnered with legendary for
a new original live action show based on
the creatures and the mysterious monster
tracking organization monarch as seen in
the movies
um
our friend i'm not sure he's your friend
he's my friend matt fraction
is going to be an executive producer
matt fraction who wrote the hawkeye
comics that everybody knows and loves
matt fractured he wrote casanova
matt fraction who wrote odyssey a sort
of space frank version of the iliad um
matt fraction's a lovely guy and i'm
very happy for him that he's getting to
take a big ass swing had a big ass
franchise like godzilla
man
pitch a theme song go for it
up from the depths
30 stories high
breathing fire head in the sky godzilla
godzilla
[Music]
i feel like they missed a trick by not
just having somebody with an acoustic
guitar in any of those godzilla movies
just sort of strumming that out
the same way you know you saw some guys
doing the original 70s animated theme to
spider-man yes
one of the greatest [ __ ] parts of the
godzilla franchise is that animated
series
song godzilla
um all right
um that's good news i mean
what they should do that that monarch
series makes a lot of sense totally and
you know apple seems to have all of the
money in the world
will john goodman be in it wasn't he
part of monarch
he was yeah he was in godzilla versus
khan he don't get killed right
i think he does
did it he does
but again
it's science fiction man nobody's dead
until you see a body
godzilla
um
i remember hearing once you know the and
i was fascinated by it
the creation of the original godzilla
roar
was a dude with a metal glove
rubbing his hand up and down a cello
and like then put through a process of
it even in like 1954 whenever that first
movie came out it was just that
and it's just it's just that
like
it's right along there with how we make
a lightsaber noise well we're going to
electrify this wand and wave it in front
of a tv and then you get the
room that's the the old school ben bert
way
um you know i think that there was some
kind of theremin involved maybe for
making the doctor who
tardis warping sound or whatever
just the the creation of the classic
sounds that we know of in hollywood was
always incredibly low-tech
you know i think was it on one of those
documentaries of ben berg just standing
there with a wrench hammering attention
wires to telephone poles to get the
laser beam shout out
um someone in chat said uh melanin x
haleed said don't forget about the
batman funeral scene leak guys did you
see this i did not see this i thought i
was stoned the other night man i'm so
glad somebody said this because i was
like holy [ __ ] i watched a whole ass
scene from the batman
that was just online and it was like at
the end of it they were like the batman
rated pg blah blah blah
but it was a whole
uncut scene at the wake or the funeral
where the car comes driving through
but it wasn't like a trailer it was a
[ __ ] scene and i was
somebody it was in my twitter [ __ ]
stream and then it like disappeared but
i was so glad i watched it and i'm not
smart enough to capture it i was trying
to figure out like i was gonna play it
on on my
laptop and then
[ __ ] shoot it with my phone but for
some reason i can't get to twitter from
my laptop lately i think i have to
upgrade
but i'm telling you like it was a it was
like a decent two three minute scene
from the movie and i got the distinct
impression
since nobody was talking about it in the
press that we were not supposed to see
it it was some sort of [ __ ] accident
and it looked good man yeah
yeah it looked moody as [ __ ] like it was
a good scene
um and it's him as bruce wayne
um
yeah it was good but i i won i'm glad
somebody said that
um
anybody else see this or was i
centered i mean according to ob kenobi
obi-wan kenobi wasn't a leak wb released
that to advertise the movie then where
is it why can't
you try finding it earlier today on
their channel
i guess the warner brothers channel
the hell's the warner brothers channel
well on youtube you know whatever
they're
is it up there right now
this obi-wan in the chat was like it he
watched it today i don't know
everyone's saying it's on youtube
funeral scene youtube
yeah i saw it too is it still up there
i don't know
i mean that's
damn [ __ ] crazy yes [ __ ] showing up
in uh
in search results for youtube not from
warner brothers though like
some other guy
is it called the funeral scene
funeral scene extended the batman 2022
official clip
what like what what what like when homer
found you know mr sparkle
and he's like it's me
but it's this this is so weird like
no people are saying it's unofficial
um
it if i got the distinct impression i
wasn't supposed to be seeing it but it's
it would shock me if it's still up
because i thought
they would like [ __ ]
it's a screen culture clip ignore
pretty sure it was an international
trailer this wasn't a trailer it was a
whole [ __ ] scene
um
is one of those scenes like when you
pull up netflix and you hover over a
title and instead of a trailer it's just
a random scene from a movie
yeah it was a whole scene at the end of
it you heard like a voiceover go the
batman rated pg 13 or whatever [ __ ]
that's so weird now playing in theaters
like it was meant for later on
whoops
well it must have been one or two of the
two hours and 55 minutes that is the run
time from matt reeves is batman
maybe that's why they can let it go out
there like hey man we got 252 more of
that
where that came from it's uh it's the
longest running time for any solo batman
movie
and one of the longest for any
theatrical superhero movie behind end
game which is three hours in one minute
um
i think zack snyder's justice league cut
is the championship uh length it's got
the length and the girth
at four hours and two minutes long
but
damn three hours of batman is a lot of
[ __ ] battery
man i'll watch [ __ ] 10 hours straight
i feel like if you're going to make it
through three hours of batman you might
need to take with you
the darkest batman movie ever which gets
a suitably dark tie-in
pizza
from little caesars
the batman calzone have you seen the
batman calzone
are you [ __ ] me they're they're
doing little caesars is doing a batman
themed pizza yes the famous pizza joint
described the new baptistic menu item as
the batman calzone is created by
combining a pizza lover's own dynamic
duo calzone and pizza
the bat-shaped product features a
tantalizing favorite profile of buttery
tasting calzone crust filled with white
garlic sauce cheese and julienne
pepperoni combined with a pepperoni
pizza and served with a side of crazy
sauce
yeah
it doesn't seem like especially this
incarnation which seems a lot more emo
doesn't doesn't really
feel like a pizza guy but like jason
found it
oh
it looks more like eagley than a
than a bat pizza none more dark batman
calzone
batman none more dark batman pizza
tie-in
that actually looks pretty good
yeah
only if it was vegan though if not for
all that cheese and pepper honey
um
some people are saying it was a leak of
a super bowl clip
when is this a bowl of super that people
talk about mark
um it is in
this sunday is the
divisional playoff games then it's a
week off for next sunday so it's the
11th i believe
i will check my calendar
bam
oh february 13th 13th
yeah
he literally came in just to say that
13th
um all right man that's it brother
that's all the news we got that's all
the news we got there it is kids you
wanted to know the news mark
brought you the news
got news
give it up for mark bringing you the
news uh banff man
oh man
i guess it's time
start uh
asking we those questions three
all right so these are all
kind of in the same
kind of
they're very similar but have very
distinct differences for questions today
uh we'll start with
zb in chat
asked uh boafette wants to ride a rancor
uh what mythical beasts from pop culture
would you want to ride or have as a pet
falcor from the never ending story
comes with that cool song
flies
[ __ ] luck dragon
[ __ ]
that or a bantha
but you know what [ __ ] panthers they
don't go anywhere they walk around
really slowly yeah yeah no yeah i'm the
falc i'm taking
either falcore or falco
so i can rock the amadeus
rock me amadeus amadeus amadeus
amadeus
what about you what about the mythosaur
can i choose that
uh i suppose you could i'm not gonna
stop
[ __ ] take over mandalore and [ __ ]
ride the great myth of mythosaur
um
what about you i keep i keep getting
stuck on [ __ ] pegasus from clash of
the titans um
or any version of pegasus really
um even the one from the tristar logo
i mean especially the one from the
tristar
like
that a slow motion is cool um i wonder
if there are unicorn pegasuses
so you get the best of both worlds
you've got a horse
surf and turf
uh look at you man it's not even good
enough to have just one mythical beast
you're like i want i want something even
rarer than a unicorn even rarer than a
pegasus i want a unicorn pegasus
i want a unisys i just want to like
cross breed them it's like listen i know
it was really hard to get these two but
i bet you they'd [ __ ] and then we could
have a kid who's got a horn and wings
who's better than us we win everything
and so yes i want to i wanna pegacorn
or eunices
um
failing
falcore
uh cringer slash battle cat because you
get two
mythical beasts for the price of one
because you can hang out with [ __ ]
cringer and stuff like that look out for
him and
and then [ __ ] like he turns hard ass
when you point your [ __ ] sword of
power at him
you could hang out with that guy too you
can get a beer with that version of
[ __ ]
battle cat
avenger man you'd like [ __ ] tell your
problems too and [ __ ]
i mean i feel like there's some and he
doesn't seem to mind being ridden you
never once heard cringer be like get off
why don't you walk
i feel like there's some richmond having
a beast that can talk because you also
want to have a friend
it's true but then you can't jerk off in
front of them because they could be like
eww
i jerk off in this very room and the dog
sits in the bed and everyone smiles like
yeah and goes back to sleep but
you wouldn't get that with cringe or
could you be like don't do it kev don't
touch yourself
and then he might go [ __ ] battle cat
on you be like ah
quit touching your your peter
your little sword of power
look i don't know if there's gonna be a
season two of masters of the universe
but i probably just lost that job
but there's been right there
adam just keeps jerking off in front of
cringer and cringers giving him [ __ ] for
it
that's weird
and they called me too woke
i wasn't sure he could get it up again
what about you uh what about what okay
what what
yeah i was i was then just thinking
about [ __ ]
um those talking polar bears the war
polar bears in in um
the [ __ ] is that again golden cop
golden accomplished [ __ ] dark his dark
material materials
i thought you were going for the
coca-cola commercial polar bears
i was like oh he likes them seasonal
bears
[Laughter]
i like the bears from those uh those
sherman ads the red bears they're like
my hat is clean
sherman clean my heart is like yeah give
me a [ __ ] bear he's all about his
like you know rectum cleanliness
there's a bear [ __ ] in the woods he does
and then he wipes his ass with cottonell
i really did
um so yeah i feel like maybe those war
polar bears are kind of cool because
they fight and they do bad ass [ __ ] but
also you could talk to them and maybe
they would
what
francis santos and chad is saying over
and over again aslan
from narnia but that would be like
owning jesus yeah
like jesus is literally your co-pilot
and maybe i don't want that so much
well more than that it's like you don't
want to be like uh this is my pet
jesus like you know
you let them go well no because they're
they're mythical they don't mean they
would be pets they could be friends like
a lot of these are talking and stuff
and they'll let you know like [ __ ] i
don't i'm not a pet i'm an equal you
know like oh [ __ ] i never thought about
that i think i would rather have mufasa
than aslan
ooh say it again
say it again
sanchez look at me
oh yeah there you go man give me all
three of them dragons so you could just
be like dracaris
i mean it's hard to go and drive through
when a dragon though and that would
really cramp my style
you could ride a moon yeah
you'd have to wait
with cheese
well done
you [ __ ] up my all day [ __ ] you on the
drive-thru
um all right we got one down one under
our belt come on banff man bring it
uh okay grassy hill wanted to know
um
boba has a mythosaur
has a mud horn
what would your symbol be on your armor
i don't think it needs to be a
mystical beast i think it could be
anything
wow what a great question
what would be my sigil
nice
um
[Music]
well i'm not a bong guy but i guess a
lit joint or a pot leaf
but you know that's not just mine that'd
be a lot of people i believe belong to a
big house if it's a bot leaf
um let's see
oh
that is the way oh a backwards baseball
cap that's my sigil
nice excellent
sometimes with horns sometimes
without horns
i think we had we'd crown sourced we had
group thunk
uh my sigil which was the the skunk
crossbones but the bones were quills
that's cute
yeah
and the skull is still a skull is it a
punisher skull
uh i don't think so i think it's more of
the you know the last poor yorick i knew
in welsco
um so it's the hamlet skull and then the
the
the
the quills in their little ink pots
make it the new punisher skull that's
like kind of like an onion
okay
that made everyone happy
okay
um
i like it yeah
that's cool
banff man you're giving us easy [ __ ]
layups here man
bamf all right
third question we had two people ask the
same question independent
uh so brian lawson and fraser lomas
both wanted to know
uh with
mandalorian getting his new spaceship
i think we have to discount the
millennium falcon
uh
what would
your spaceship of choice be
and how would you modify it so you get
to add a special modification
why can't i have the millennium falcon
why'd you take that away
because everybody would have the
millennium falcon
i a i would never have thought to choose
the millennium falcon it's the hunk of
junk
i feel like i want something sleek
i feel like it's a character though i
feel like that's everybody's go to
um let me see
i mean
i had the millennium falcon when i was a
kid it wasn't all that was cracked up to
be
one the fastest ship in the galaxy it
was a [ __ ] toy
does my ship have to be star wars or can
it be anything be anything
i want the nautilus i want the nautilus
man man in a minute
man i want to go 20 000 leagues under
the sea i want to see some [ __ ] up
fish
you need a nautilus
there ain't enough [ __ ] up fish in
this world man we've seen all the fishes
and they all look the same but deep in
the ocean in the ocean deep down into
mariana and a trench they got them
[ __ ] up fish that nobody ever sees and
if i had that ship with the big bubble
eyes and whatnot i'd be sitting there
playing piano looking out the window and
[ __ ] up fish as they went by
oh i'd be so happy finally i'd be whole
mark
finally i would be me
take me down to that marianist trench
where did he go he took his very
penis-looking ship to the marianist
trench as he called it
and we haven't seen him since he's
probing for stuff
uh what about you uh i was a big fan of
a show called uh g-force when i was a
kid
which may or may not be more familiar as
battle of the planet battle of the
planets we're off to outer space we're
leaving mother earth
to save the human race that's a
different show star blue it is the star
blazers because this was like
they didn't have any lyrics they just
had big music yeah they're like big
[ __ ] horns but they had a ship called
the phoenix
which was like a normal [ __ ] cool
ship it was like blue with red stuff and
phoenix but then when it became the
fiery phoenix it just blew into [ __ ]
flames and it was also somewhat alive at
that moment
but
oh [ __ ]
like
it's [ __ ] badass and so when i was 11
that was the [ __ ] that i always wanted
and i still want it because i feel like
you get all the dracara's fun about
flaming [ __ ] you don't like but
also a really [ __ ] rad spaceship when
it's not that
my backup is just a standard ass
landspeeder
really
yeah man when i was a kid i always found
it it captured my imagination like and
i'm a local guy i could use that get
around and [ __ ] go to the
[ __ ] you know whole foods and [ __ ]
there's not a lot of trunk space in
those things but you know it's like i'm
gonna fly i just cruise yeah
all right you go high you can crash
i just want to hover off the ground this
much
that's why i don't ride horses either
mark that's a high height to fall off a
thing
yeah no and also they're alive and they
got like will of their own
i wouldn't mind a tie fighter either
it's a cool you can't really like roll
with a couple of people though like it's
it's very much
like a solitary it's a solo flight it's
a very masturbatory ship it is what are
we doing here just catching some rays
soaking up these solar panels
i'm gonna stick with i'm sticking with
the nautilus man because you can get a
lot of people on it or wait a second
wait for it
there's another submarine
and it's yellow
and it will protect us from the blue
meanies
i like how you're like spaceship [ __ ]
you give me a submarine i just want to
stay on this planet just hide from
everybody well i want to go into space
underwater under the water i didn't know
was it a spaceship i just thought it was
a craft of some sort
banff man was it a spaceship or was it
just a sh
uh
let's see
um
[Music]
sci-fi vehicle
sci-fi vehicle
you want
yeah wait sci-fi vehicle oh [ __ ]
batmobile hands down
the anton first [ __ ] 1989 batmobile
and i want a little one from mtv in a
[ __ ] fair world
some other guy won it i called once
and i didn't win
i've always wanted mad max's car
the the ford falcon
the loss of the v it interceptors it's a
piece of history right
i always wanted that [ __ ] car um
hard to find given that it was only made
in australia and they're they were only
made in like the 70s but
with the giant [ __ ] engine on top i
did dig that that uh that didn't
jarrings
[ __ ] naboobian fighter they put a big
ass carburetor on top of it
like that was just a hot rod that was
just
no she sounds just fine i can hear it in
my head like not everything's firing
gray you should take it up see what's
happening under there that's a pretty
good amy sedaris
i tried my best tardis i see lots of
people in the chat pitching a tardis
also a very good call
some people have brought up the tron
bikes aka the light cycles
those look dangerous to me
i don't want that and also like you can
fall off a bike and you can hurt your
legs batmobile it's a [ __ ] tank and
you know what maybe not the anton first
batmobile maybe frank miller's [ __ ]
dark knight returns batmobile the
[ __ ] tank
it's not bad i like the batman in the
animated series batmobile that was
always one of my favorites that was a
nice one too
but the dark knight returns one man the
[ __ ] nose cone can look down at the
mutant leader where he's like batman
fight me
rubber bullets
and [ __ ] the guys like batman don't
shiv
[Laughter]
there's some good uh bunch of people
saying eagle eagle one from spaceballs
like
that you could drive it
sci-fi vehicle
i stand by the nautilus man
or batmobile yeah
i mean click it more duck with the
batmobile than the nautilus
kit's a good call
um
delorean's a great call from back to the
future
i think i would go with like
astro train from transformers like you
could go up into space where you could
take a nice leisurely stroll across the
country in train mode and if like [ __ ]
got real
you could become a big robot
i got i i don't know i've got i'm not
issues but i'm a little reticent
to be engaged with vehicles that have
personalities and are living things and
crawling up inside of them and whatnot
what if he transforms and i'm in there
i'm like crushed so it's a joke we did
on the clerk's cartoon
ecto one somebody said ryan fajardo and
chat
yeah
really it's just an old hearse like or
didn't really
it doesn't have any magic powers i'll
take some chitty chitty bang bang for
200
[Music]
i would uh i would do the heart of gold
which is the spaceship from hitchhiker's
guide to the galaxy's guide yes
oh what about the lotus from the spy who
loved me a [ __ ] car turns into a
submarine it's the best of both worlds
man
heaven above me
the spy who love me
he has a car that goes under water
could you imagine
i mean i guess they got those now right
those duck boats you go and [ __ ]
drive around the city with a
body of water next to it yeah i mean i
think they actually built i think
they built a lotus that could go as a
submarine
for the movie
it's hella leaky
i don't think it was meant to do that
for a long time
and because i remember somebody bought
one because they had the [ __ ] picture
cars and they didn't went up on auction
so yeah this really can't go underwater
anymore because they're actually not
really airtight
i remember they told us our whole lives
volkswagens were airtight
and then uh 1992 there was a nor'easter
that struck the east coast and
um jason muse and i jason muse who plays
jay to my silent bub
we had two cars together two cheap cars
that he was fixing one we were going to
sell
when we were keeping to drive between us
we split insurance insurance very
expensive in new jersey even back then
so
night before the nor'easter you know
reports are coming in it's going to be a
big storm you know move all the vehicles
we uptown because highlands our home
town is below sea level
so uh muse calls me up jay
irresponsible knuckleheaded young jay
calls me up to be like and he's four
years younger than me and i'm 22 so this
is
you know he's 18.
he's like
we should move the two volkswagens up we
had a volkswagen bug and a volkswagen
rabbit he said we should move him uptown
man they say the storm's gonna be bad i
was like listen jay
i said i live on jackson street we live
right down the [ __ ] street from the
bulkhead
even when it gets the worst in terms of
flooding the water never gets up to our
driveway it's just in the street so
no i'm not getting up and moving the car
and i'm not going to give you the keys
to move the car either because you can't
be trusted mr irresponsible
good night so i go to bed
and i'm awakened
very early by my mother in a panic
he's like get out of bed if you want to
save your comic books you better get out
of bed right now and i was like what the
what a weird thing to wake up to and i
went to get out of bed and i put my foot
down on the wall-to-wall carpet that my
mother had in my room as a kid
and
the carpet
was higher than it normally was
and my foot sank into it and
water enveloped my foot
like suddenly the water like the water
it was such a big nor'easter such a big
flood
water flooded our house it was coming up
through the floorboards of our house
something that never happened before so
when i stepped on that big thing i was
like oh my god and i went and grabbed
all my comics from the bottom shelf
of uh in my room and put them all on the
bed i quick ran to the living room to
look out the window
at the two cars that jason had begged me
to move up up town and one of the last
things i said to him was even if it
flooded
they're volkswagens they're airtight
and i looked out the window mark and i
saw a [ __ ] fish
in the car swimming
volkswagen is not an airtight car
but he's judging the imagination
and we lost both of those [ __ ] cars
in the flood man totaled out couldn't
[ __ ] save him so p.s to that story
fema the federal emergency management
agency comes to highlands our town that
was ravaged by
the 92 nor'easter december of 92. and
they set up shop and they you know go
hey what'd you lose file for it and we
can get you some federal money man
and so jay's like we should go
and we should file for the cars i'm like
listen jay
they're not gonna give us any money for
those cars this is all about people with
houses
he's like we should try anyway so we go
to borough hall
and they're like the fema you know agent
is there there's many in the room in the
in the empty firehouse
and uh they're like what did you lose
what are you claiming
and jay's like um we lost a volkswagen
and a volkswagen rabbit in the flood
and the lady was like are you brothers
and he's like no
you just own cars together
and she was like okay fill out this
paperwork and
we filled it out and i was like listen
here jay
this ain't ever gonna [ __ ] work and
lo and behold
[ __ ] federal government which my
father cursed almost every day of his
life because he worked at the post
office and hated working for the federal
government federal government cut me and
muse the [ __ ] check muse called me
one day to be like i got a check here
for four thousand dollars they gave us
two thousand dollars a piece for those
cars cars that we had bought for like
three hundred dollars a piece
and we're working on like refurbishing
so we couldn't flip one and stuff like
that
and that money you know we split it and
jason got two thousand i got two
thousand guess what i did with my two
thousand dollars mark why it went to a
little motion picture by the name of
clerks yes
the federal emergency management agency
helped finance clerks
now i'm sure in chat there are a bunch
of people like you misused government
funds you [ __ ] prick how is that a
cool story well it happened in the early
90s when you could get away with things
like that
or there was such a thing as the social
contract and responsibility i was a kid
what did i know i just wanted to make my
movie
but yeah fema money paid for a bit of
clerks
and here i thought you were gonna say i
bought two thousand dollars for the
comic books
i bought two thousand burritos a dollar
a pop
and i sat there one summer day and ate
them all
i tried once when it was like three
years ago
burger king had some promotion where she
would buy 10 nuggets for a dollar
and i was working i think the treadstone
writer's room at the time and i said
guys
for a hundred dollars we can get a
thousand chicken nuggets
i don't want to eat a thousand chicken
nuggets i just want to see what a
thousand chicken nuggets looks like
let's go do it and then we're all like
no that's weird i'm like yeah but come
on man so you'll blow up out your
stomach i'm not gonna eat this
[ __ ] tv writers
let's spend some dumb money on dumb [ __ ]
and nobody would do it with me and i've
always regretted it because i wanted to
see what a thousand chicken letters look
like you should come with me to the
flash television show that shoots up in
vancouver i think when i was there for
my second episode malcolm was with me
and i was like
malcolm i want to bring in
tim bits but i want to bring a like a
ghastly amount of timbits i said will
you call up
uh t hoes tim hortons
and see how much a thousand timbits
would cost
and you know it wasn't cheap but all
things considered
it wasn't as expensive as you would
imagine i think it was somewhere in the
200 range
you know and there's a big crew on the
flash you know and you don't just eat
one tin bit and that's it
you know you could sit there and snack
all day
so i was like let's do it let's [ __ ]
pull the trigger i was like a thousand
timbits please there's a long [ __ ]
silence on the phone and they're like
all right you can get that in 30 minutes
and
pick them up and in your head you're
like a thousand timbits we better bring
a big car
three boxes
[Laughter]
wasn't that big so we laid them out
on on set it's in my instagram there's
pictures of it somewhere way back in the
day
but we laid out all the [ __ ] timbits
and it did look impressive when everyone
saw we kept inviting other shows over
like hey riverdale come get some free
timbits
um you know there were so many that
people were whipping them at each other
at the end of the day
and if you're like that's a waste of
food i mean these are [ __ ] donuts
it's not
food food yeah
yeah i mean someday some days soon i
will make my nugget prince come
um
my nugget prince will come somebody in
uh a chat said what the [ __ ] is a tin
bit tim bit it's uh here in america we
have dunkin donuts and they're
the donut holes are called munchkins
up in the great white north they have a
series of uh donatarius coffee shops
called tim hortons
t hoes if you will and their donut holes
are called timbits
i honestly didn't think i would have to
explain that but i now realize that some
people in the audience are neither from
america
nor canada
a decent drug of people from america
have no experience with its importance
that's true they try to open in a few
uh over the course of the last 10 years
down here there's one in like new york
city in times square but i think
most of them have kind of
gone back there i think they thrive near
the top near the border
like top of the american border because
you got enough
you know folks who know what a
double-double is
you know it's not an in-n-out sandwich
it's a
coffee
uh at tim tio's i can't believe we're
still talking about tim hortons moving
on
we have no more questions
that's what happened we ran out of
questions was that all the questions man
jc
yeah that's three
there it is you wanted to know [ __ ]
we now you know [ __ ]
if you didn't know
now you know
and knowing is half the battle
[Music]
or you know
um let me tell you something kids
we had a good time tonight
good ass time talking about shows we
love and things we love and
and giggling and singing
i mean this is like going to camp for
the last few hours
and if you uh if you're happy that you
went to camp
uh thank jc bam boy banff man ladies and
gentlemen he made sure this show
happened i don't know if you were here
at the beginning but [ __ ] was looking
iffy we had a hero banff man had his own
hero and that guy is
will wilkins man give it up for will he
saved the show indeed
save the picture
um
food is crap the drinks are hideous we
like this on a smoking drink and full
around for no people
we are the city so
we are the north stars
[Music]
young bill murray man
magical ah
if you enjoy the show kids uh there is
no show without the guy
who sits
in the square below me but to the other
side is that right no there there it is
no there it is
there it is god
good thing i don't have to tie a tie or
anything there he is
mr mark bernardin ladies and gentlemen
oh thank you sir if you haven't had
enough of uh me kevin smith it's
thursday night
at 9 55 here on the west coast in
california uh in two days 48 hours on
saturday night
at flappers comedy club in burbank
me and ralph garman doing hollywood
babylon ladies and gentlemen tickets at
csmodd.com and hope to see you there
soon we'll be getting back into the
cantina to do fat man beyond live i know
what what do we think we think maybe oh
no bam for him banff man you got any
words bamf um
i i mean i think we could probably
target like uh
maybe
week after valentine's day
maybe give it another week we'll see how
we'll see how the numbers are trending
and then numbers seem to be trending
down am i wrong
no i think so
uh also by that point
uh
fun announcement for people
who uh who don't love drinking alcohol
we
are going to be adding cbd cocktails to
the menu
starting in the next couple weeks
so if you're like my attention sir yeah
so if you're not interested in uh
drinking booze we have an alternative
to uh help keep you centered
so those are coming up
hopefully they'll be ready by the time
we get back to the bar
so are we looking at like the 15th or
the 22nd i think we should aim for 22nd
all right
president's day show our favorite
fictional science fictional presence
uh you know we say it's night time and
the moon is out you know what we say
when the moon is out at night
i'm conscious i'm
oh man the three hour shows
i like it when we get punchy at the end
this is like at the end of snl when they
do the weird sketches in the last
five minutes
like anybody still awake hit him with
the [ __ ] weird yeah let's see if
they're paying attention
uh there it is kids you have a good time
i sure did so did mark man someone go to
jc
come back next week we're gonna do more
of this type of [ __ ] man next week we'll
be talking about more
book of boba fett more
peacemaker and more of anything else
that uh needs
and demands our attention and yours
hope you had a great time ladies and
gentlemen you go have
a wonderful night thank you for keeping
me so preoccupied i forgot to eat
and so that you know i
wound up having a 24-hour fast without
even thinking about it
well done man who's better than you
uh that's it
for fat man beyond for this week this
last week of january 2022
i'm kevin smith i am mark bernard
tune in next week
or next time same
fat time same
fat channel spodcast.com or
youtube.com kevin smith
a thousand jeff's kisses to you all
[Music]
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask of anything every saga has a
10-year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens with jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith